Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum ersten WM-Panel im Rasenfunk, zu dieser Männerweltmeisterschaft 2026 in den USA, Kanada und Mexiko. Und ich orientiere mich gleich an den ausufernden Eröffnungszeremonien vor den WM-Spielen, die wir sehen werden, indem ich jetzt schon alle Gäste vorstelle, sogar die, die nicht im aktuellen Spieltags-Kader stehen, werdet ihr gleich verstehen. Ich begrüße hier Inga Hofmann vom Tagesspiegel. Ich freue mich total, sie mal wieder im Rasenfunk begrüßen zu dürfen. Hallo Inga.
Ich freue mich auch riesig, schön wieder hier zu sein.
Außerdem ist da Eva-Lotta Bohle, die heute allein drei, in dieser Woche allein drei Rasenfunk-Sendungen entweder mitproduziert hat oder daran als Gast teilnimmt. Also Eva, herzlich willkommen im Team. Mal wieder, schön, dass du da bist.
Danke für die Einladung. Ja, ist aber ganz, ja, neues Terra quasi, muss man ja schon sagen. Also ist nicht die feine, aber kleine Zweitliga-Welt.
Ja, ja gut. Aber das ist, aber von der Länge her hast du dich schon mal gut eingegroovt. Dreieinhalb Stunden Zweitliga-Rückblick, Respekt. Aber ich wusste ja, warum ich dich so gerne hier im Rasenfunk habe. Und ebenso ist es mit Jürgen Kalwa. Er ist freier Sportjournalist. Ihr kennt ihn wahrscheinlich schon aus Rasenfunk-Sendungen. Unter anderem haben wir ja die Geschichte des Fußballs in den USA aufgearbeitet. Jürgen lebt auch drüben. Schön, dass du da bist, Jürgen, mal wieder.
Ja, gleichzeitig frage ich mich aber, also der DFB will sich nicht aus dem Spiel nehmen, was bedeutet, er will das Spiel mitspielen? Und dann ist ja schon die Frage, an welchem Punkt möchte man da mal einen Kontrapunkt setzen? Und man muss das jetzt nicht gleichsetzen mit Argentinien 78. Das wäre auch völlig falsch, weil da haben wir von dem Militär runtergesprochen und der Fall der Studentin Elisabeth Käsemann im Jahr davor, die ihm entführt und ermordet wurde. Und ziemlich sicher mit einem Eingreifen des DFB hätte gerettet werden können, so wie es nämlich der englischen Mitstudentin, die auch entführt wurde. Dann passiert es unmittelbar rund um ein Länderspiel, das da stattfand, ein Freundschaftsspiel des DFB da. Das kann eine Warnung sein, da muss man sich aber mit diesem Fall auch auskennen, um das zu wissen. Und ich wäre mir ehrlich gesagt nicht mal sicher, ob Bernd Neuendorf das schon so drauf hat. Aber die Frage ist, wir sprechen jetzt hier über einen Schiedsrichter, der nicht einreißen darf. Wir sprechen darüber, dass einem Team letztlich der sportlich gleiche Wettbewerb verwehrt wird, weil sie eben nicht dieselben Anreise- und Abreisebedingungen haben, wie alle anderen Teams. Und wir sprechen ja auch nicht darüber, dass jetzt hier jemand, es muss sich ja nicht Joshua Kimmich hinstellen, ich muss sagen, das finde ich jetzt aber ganz doof. Liebe FIFA, tun sie was. Aber man könnte ja zum Beispiel in Europa Allianzen schmieden. Es gab ja durchaus schon mal die Zusammenarbeit verschiedenster Verbände, die sich dann geäußert haben. Und gleichzeitig stellt man sich die Frage, wofür, Bernd Neuendorf, sitzen sie denn dann eigentlich im FIFA Council? Wenn sie dann da sitzen und sagen, ja, aber ich kann jetzt leider nicht widersprechen, weil dann finden mich alle hier doof. Und dann passiert dasselbe wie 2022. Und hinterher wirkt es sich auch noch auf sportlich aus. Das ist natürlich das letzte, was wir wollen. Und da würde ich dann schon gerne mal die Frage beantwortet haben, also wenn jetzt der Schiedsrichter des Jahres in Afrika, ich überstrapaziere diesen Punkt vielleicht ein bisschen, aber wenn der nicht einreisen darf, obwohl er einen Diplomatenpass hat. Also, was muss denn dann noch passieren? Muss ein ganzes Team nicht einreißen dürfen, dass man dann vielleicht mal sagt, liebe FIFA, ihr habt ja den sehr, sehr guten Draht zu Donald Trump, wollt ihr ihn nicht vielleicht mal aktivieren an dieser Stelle? Das ist schon so die Frage, die ich hier mal so in den Raum stellen wollen würde.
Also, ich kann da ja nochmal Axel Hellmann zitieren, der hat damals im Besagengespräch auch sowas gesagt, also man solle jetzt nicht auch irgendwie vom Fußball erwarten, dass er die Politik regulieren würde. Also sowas hat er quasi gesagt und auch noch ganz wilde andere Sachen.
Der hat noch nie ein WM-Spiel ausgerichtet. Da sieht er nämlich mal, wie der Fußball regulieren kann.
Na, aber das ist dann, also ich habe bei sowas immer ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass FIFA, DFB und Co., also Fußballfans, auch allgemein für naiv und einfach so hinnehmend wahrnehmen. Also und klar, wir werden gleich noch auf die Ticketanfragen kommen und so und da werden auch wieder genug Leute hinfahren. Und ich sage auch ehrlich, natürlich ist es für mich moralisch nicht vertretbar, da hinzureißen, das sage ich ganz klar. Und ich wüsste auch nicht, was ich da sollte. Gleichzeitig kann ich zum Beispiel Fans vom Irak, wo diese Mannschaft das erste Mal seit 40 Jahren und überhaupt das zweite Mal in ihrer Historie überhaupt so eine WM bestreitet. Ja, HUMI zu sagen, so ja, das ist aber moralisch nicht ganz fair, ne? Aber ich, also, ich glaube da halt einfach nicht dran, dass die, dass irgendwer, also ich kann da auch empfehlen, diesen aktuellen Podcast vom, ich glaube, Deutschlandfunk zu hören, wo sie eben auch rund um Infantino einen Podcast gemacht haben. Und man einfach da nochmal merkt, wie tief diese Korruption ist. Und so, da wird einfach, ich habe da einfach kein Vertrauen, dass sie sich weder hier im DFB in welche Allianz bilden werden, mit anderen Verbänden, weil die haben ja alle ihre eigenen Probleme. Also wenn man nach Spanien guckt und so. Ja, ich habe da wenig Hoffnung. Aber die Frage ist natürlich vollkommen berechtigt.
Es ist ja auch ein bisschen die Frage, wie viel, also wie viel Druck hat der DFB? Weil, also ich bin jetzt mal gespannt, wenn Deutschland das erste Mal spielt. Aber irgendwie, also mein Eindruck ist selbst in Katar, als dann erstmal die deutsche Nationalmannschaft gespielt hat, hat sich halt wieder diese typische Dynamik entwickelt. Alle reden über Sportliche, alle haben Bock auf die Spiele und so weiter. Also die Frage ist ja auch, wie viel Druck hat der DFB überhaupt da grundlegend, was an seinem Verhalten zu ändern, da anders heranzugehen, wenn im Endeffekt dann ja doch genug Fans das belohnen, in Anführungszeichen. Und ich glaube, also weil du gesagt hast, Max, was muss denn noch passieren? Ich weiß nicht, wie es aussehen würde, wenn eine europäische Mannschaft nicht einreisen dürfte, wenn Frankreich jetzt nicht einreisen dürfte zum Beispiel. Ich glaube, alles andere ist dann genau aus einer eurozentristischen Perspektive, die wir schon hatten, vielleicht nicht bedeutungsvoll genug. Und ich glaube, es ist auch eine Gewöhnungssache leider. Also mir kommt das so ein bisschen vor wie die neue Normalität. Also nach Katar war man irgendwie ganz, ganz froh, jetzt endlich wieder in einem westlichen Land. Jetzt hat man so ein bisschen einen Realitätscheck bekommen und hat jetzt auch diese Diskussionen geführt. Und ich glaube, das haben tatsächlich gar nicht so weniger als eine Art von neuer Normalität akzeptiert.
Also ich würde gerne noch zu dieser Hellmann-Zitatssache was sagen. Das ist ein Rhetoriktrick von dem Menschen. Zu sagen, der Fußball kann doch nicht irgendwie die Politik irgendwie ändern oder so. Was kann der Fußball in Form der FIFA und die Verbände, die dahinterstehen? Er kann dafür sorgen, dass sein eigenes Turnier nach den Regeln abgewickelt wird, die sie selber gegeben haben. Das sind bestimmte moralische Ideen, aber das sind auch ganz simple, wenn man das mal juristisch runterbrechen würde. Das sind Vertragsmodelle, wie man sowas umsetzt. Und die FIFA hat mit allen Ausrichterstätten und sicherlich auch auf irgendeine Art mit der Bundesregierung Verträge. Da geht es zum Beispiel um die Steuerbefreiung. Da geht es um alle möglichen Dinge. Da war die FIFA stark genug, Dinge auf Papier zu versiegeln und zu sagen, so, das ist unser Turnier und wir haben folgende Kriterien. Und wenn ihr da nicht mitmacht, dann kriegt ihr das Turnier nicht. Wir reden hier, wenn Herr Hillmann das so unwidersprochen sagt, wir reden nicht davon, dass die Politik in den USA geändert werden soll durch die Fußballer, die da auftauchen, sondern wir reden davon, dass die FIFA ihre eigenen Regeln umsetzen muss, vertreten durch die Repräsentanten wie Infantino und wie im DFB. Und wenn die sich das nicht mal auf die Fahne schreiben können, dann muss man ihnen das auch ins Stammbuch schreiben und sagen, Leute, ihr müsst den Job nicht haben, ihr könnt ihn auch abgeben. Vielleicht an Leute, die sich mehr engagieren wollen und die mehr Energie haben oder so.
Ich wollte noch eine Sache ergänzend zu Inga sagen, weil du meintest von wegen politischer Äußerungen im Stadion, das sind ja nicht nur Vermutungen, sondern da gibt es ja seit letztem Jahr diese neuen Regularien mit einer sehr schwammigen Formulierung zu. Ich glaube, was heißt das irgendwie? Politischen Äußerungen oder so ähnlich. Also politische und sonstige Meinungen. Also das ist ja auch sehr weit gefasst und wo ich glaube, in einem Artikel der SZ eben auch gefragt wurde, ja also heißt das dann zum Beispiel, man darf korrupte Verbände nicht mehr kritisieren und weil alles ja unter diesem Deckmantel mehr gegen Rassismus zu tun. Und also die FIFA hat dann selbst auf Nachfrage gesagt, ob es für Äußerungen und Protest-Sanktionen, die zum Beispiel eine korrupte FIFA oder Donald Trump und Co. thematisieren, Infantino Sanktionen geben könnte, einfach nur so, ja das müsste man von Fall zu Fall entscheiden. Und das zeigt ja aber auch gleichzeitig, Jürgen, dass sie ja überhaupt nicht daran interessiert ist, da irgendwie das anders zu drehen, sondern sie spielt ja eben genau den Machthabern, wie Trump und Co. in die Karten damit. Und natürlich einfach weil die FIFA ja selber einfach, wie gesagt, ich empfehle sehr diesen Podcast. Man stüllt sehr, sehr häufig mit dem Kopf, gerade wenn man so die internen, man so exklusive Inhalte hört oder so. Ich, ja, also dass ich wirklich noch sprachlos sein kann bei der FIFA, das hat mich tatsächlich auch noch überrascht.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir ja aber auch eine gewisse Ambivalenz bei diesem ganzen Thema. Das würde ich gerne als letzten Punkt hier noch mal zur Sprache stellen. Denn man kann natürlich auch argumentieren, ja gut, die USA haben ja das Recht, ihre eigene Gesetzgebung erst mal so umzusetzen, wie sie es immer machen. Wir gucken halt jetzt anders drauf wegen der Weltmeisterschaft. Und ehrlicherweise, das war auch der FIFA so klar. Also wenn man sich noch mal im FIFA Bit Evaluation Report, also wo eben die WM-Bewerbung von Marokko und eben von Kanada, Mexiko und den USA nebeneinander stellt, wo die bewertet wurden von einer FIFA-Delegation, da ist genau das der Punkt, der noch mal herausgestrichen wird. Da haben beide nämlich schlecht abgeschnitten, also im Medium-Bereich. Und da steht nämlich genau das, dass bei den USA nicht ganz klar ist, ob alle auch wirklich einreisen würden können. Also sprich, man war sich dessen schon bewusst. Und gleichzeitig gibt es jetzt aber, finde ich, eine interessante Ambivalenz, die auch zeigt, wie schwierig es ist, über solche Themen zu sprechen. Denn wenn wir nämlich zum Beispiel darüber sprechen, dass es ja ungerecht gegenüber den Sportlern aus dem Iran ist, dass sie eben ganz andere Anreise- und Abreisebedingungen haben als alle anderen Teams bei dieser WM, dann sprechen wir aber gleichzeitig über ein Team, dessen Erfolg sehr wahrscheinlich vom jetzt herrschenden Regime auch ausgenutzt wird. Also ich habe zum Beispiel einen Beitrag gelesen, da hieß es, dass wohl jedes iranische Gruppenspiel in Kinos gezeigt wird. Es gab auch schon Demonstrationen von Exil-Iranerinnen und Iranern in Los Angeles. Ich habe vorhin davon gesprochen, wie groß die iranische Community dort auch ist. Und das sah aus wie eine Magher-Rallye, weil die gesagt haben, ja genau das ist richtig, die symbolischen Vertreter dieses Regimes, die sollen hier auch gar nicht einreisen, die sollen vielleicht sogar von der Weltmeisterschaft verbannt werden. Inga, wie gehst denn du mit dieser Ambivalenz um, die man eben an diesem Fall Iran ganz gut illustrieren kann? Auf der einen Seite fordern wir Gerechtigkeit, gleichzeitig wissen wir aber auch, das wird wieder instrumentalisiert werden von einem Regime, das wir alle vier hier sicherlich nicht unterstützen wollen.
Na ja, total. Das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Ja, es ist schwierig, damit umzugehen. Ich glaube, es hilft immer, auf diese Grautöne auch zu schauen. Das ist nicht so als Schwarz-Weiß. Du hast vorhin schon die iranische Diaspora, die in Los Angeles beispielsweise Großes angesprochen. Ich denke, es ist ganz wichtig, auch dahin zu schauen. Wie reagiert ihr darauf? Ich denke, man kann damit kleineren Protesten, vielleicht auch größeren Protesten, Kundgebungen und so weiter rechnen. Darauf ganz genau zu schauen. Und ja, irgendwie diese Gleichzeitigkeiten auch so ein bisschen auszuhalten. Also das, was du gerade beschrieben hast, kann ja auch stattfinden neben, oder die Kritik daran kann ja auch stattfinden neben der Kritik an der Ungleichbehandlung der verschiedenen Nationalmannschaften. Und ja, dafür eben Raum zu geben. Und ich glaube, was eigentlich auch dahinter steht, was du gerade angesprochen hast, ist, das Motto dieser WM ist ja irgendwie Football unites the world. Aber es wird auf jeden Fall immer betont, jeder wird willkommen sein. Also auch so ein bisschen dann, es geht ja vor allem darum, die FIFA auf ein Versprechen festzunageln und auf ein Konzept, was ursprünglich mal mit der Grund war, warum überhaupt diese WM dort stattfindet. Also ich würde das auch gar nicht nur so moralisch sehen, sondern vor allem, ja, was ist das Versprechen der FIFA und was wird jetzt umgesetzt? Oder das Versprechen der USA und was findet jetzt tatsächlich statt? Also genau, ich glaube, vielleicht diese Grautöne zu beleuchten und diese Gleichzeitigkeiten auszuhalten, die das eine als andere auch nicht ausschließt.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist noch, wenn man das jetzt mal kurz von der sportlichen Seite aus angeht, dieses Mammut-Format. Du weißt ja gar nicht genau, wo du hingucken sollst. Also wir sind alle inzwischen auch so medienbewusst und konditioniert, dass wir also auch so bestimmte Triggerpunkte haben und sagen, okay, das sind die Favoriten oder das sind die Außenseite, aber mit Chancen oder wenn man sich die deutsche Mannschaft anschaut, sieht man eben ein Generationswechsel und eine bestimmte Spielkultur, die sich da entwickelt. Also macht es auch Spaß, den zuzuschauen und so. Also es gibt so viele andere Dinge, die man gar nicht richtig einnorden kann. Also diese, sind wir da schon auf der Metaebene? Ich weiß nicht. Also die Wahrnehmung dieser Veranstaltung, die findet bei mir, wenn ich jetzt nicht beruflich irgendwie ganz stark involviert bin, die findet bei mir in einer ganz eigenartigen Zone im Gehirn statt. Ich kann das gar nicht mehr richtig begreifen, was das ist. Ich bin vielleicht auch zu alt und habe auch noch Turniere mit 16 Mannschaften in Erinnerung. Und ein Turnier, da war ich noch ganz klein, da waren mindestens, da waren glaube ich alle vier englischen Verbände in Schweden, alle vier englischen Verbände hatten sich qualifiziert. Wales, England, Schottland, glaube ich, korrigiere mich, Max und Nordirland. Solche Bündelungen, solche Überlegungen, wie entwickelt sich Fußball und so weiter, das kann man hier alles irgendwie nicht zu packen kriegen. Also außer ihr seid schon weiter, weil ihr seid auch erfahrene Rasenfunk-Menschen, ihr denkt dauernd über auch das Grundsätzliche im Fußball. Ja, dann helft ihr mir bitte vielleicht an dieser Stelle mal ein, ja, also ihr seht meine Hände hier, also wie kriege ich das irgendwie gepackt, was das sportlich zum Beispiel ist. Jetzt mal unabhängig, ja, wir haben ja nun auch schon relativ ausführlich über all dieses Drumherum gesprochen. Ich will mich ja irgendwie auf diese Spiele irgendwie einlassen, aber wie?
Naja, also Anpfiff und dann, es wird gepfiffen zum Anpfiff, das Spiel geht los nach einer endlosen Zeremonie vor riesigen Flacken und dann analysierst du, dann guckst du, was machen die taktisch, dann zählt nur das Spiel. Wenn dann was politisches außen rum passiert, okay alles klar, nimmt man auf, kann man aber auch nach dem Apfiff dann nochmal drüber nachdenken. So machs ich ehrlicherweise und ich will das auch nochmal betonen, weil der Rasenfunk kommt auch oft so moralin sauer her, das liegt auch immer an meinen endlosen Monologen. Aber jeder und jede darf Spaß an dieser Weltmeisterschaft haben und soll auch gerne. Weil das Spiel ist immer noch gut, es kann gut sein, dass ich auch Spaß daran haben werde. Ich weiß es noch nicht, aber bei mir ist es tatsächlich so, mit dem Apfiff zählt für mich nur das Sportliche, dann guck ich nicht drauf, was der Linksverteidiger mal politisch so gesagt hat, was ich vielleicht doof finde, sondern ich guck erst mal nur drauf, wie er läuft und was er so macht. Und mit dem Apfiff dann überlege ich mir, welche anderen Dinge für mich jetzt noch eine Rolle gespielt haben. Aber so schaffe ich eigentlich dann, deswegen habe ich den Spaß an diesem Spiel immer noch nicht verloren. Ich weiß nicht, Eva, wie du es machst. Ich meine, bei dir ist es noch härter, weil du guckst Zweitliga-Fußball.
Hallo, was soll das denn jetzt heißen? Da muss ich mir wenigstens keine Gedanken machen, ob die Spieler irgendwie für jede Nationalmannschaft ausspielen oder so und dann vernetzt werden. Nee, ich finde es so interessant, weil ich kann es halt nicht mehr bei so vielen Spielen. Also ich weiß nicht, mir ging es bei der EM 2024 schon so, dass ich irgendwann da das Gefühl hatte, dass es dann auch direkt danach wieder die Saison losging, gefühlt. Also Max, du wirst es mehr wissen, weil du guckst dir halt wirklich jeden Spieltag diese neun Bundesliga der Männer. Und sechs?
Sieben.
Sieben sind es inzwischen genau bei der Frauen an. Du hast da noch viel mehr, aber mir ging es halt, also ich habe halt so eine Übersättigung generell und für mich schreit halt dieses Gigaturnier nicht, boah geil, noch mehr Fußball, sondern ach du meine Güte, noch mehr Spiele. Als du mich angefragt hast, ich dachte so, oh Gott, jetzt muss ich diese ganzen Spiele kochen. Und du warst so, wann soll ich das schaffen? Oder habe ich da überhaupt Lust zu? Und keine Ahnung, also ich fand es zum Beispiel auch irgendwann bei der WM der Frauen in Australien, ich wusste irgendwann, ich wusste nicht mehr, welche Spiele ich wann gesehen habe. Und ich finde es einfach, also wenn wir wirklich nur beim rein sportlich-analytischen bleiben, ich kann überhaupt irgendwann nicht mehr zuordnen, was ich wo, wann, wie irgendwann gesehen habe. Und finde es dann deshalb total schwierig zu packen, ehrlich gesagt. Und ja, gerade, also wenn man dann schon, bevor dieses Turnier gespielt wurde, ich glaube vor anderthalb Jahren, dann hat Infantino gesagt, ja, wir können ja überlegen, dann das nächste Turnier mit 64 Mannschaften und so. Und dann, also das Schlimme ist ja, es macht ja nur die Gruppenphase immer größer. Also erzähle damit nichts Neues. Aber also wenn wir uns, Inga, ich gehe damit, ich kann mit Zahlen noch erst mal relativ wenig anfangen. Aber das wird ja, also nur weil ich mehr Vereine, Teams habe, wird dir das Turnier an sich im Endkern, in diesen Endrunden, nicht groß interessanter, weil am Ende landen gefühlt er doch trotzdem immer zu 80 Prozent die gleichen Mannschaften. Und das ist halt für mich dieses, so ich mir, also da sehe ich diesen sportlichen, diese sportliche Interesse irgendwie nicht so richtig hinter.
Gleichzeitig, Inga, hatten wir das ja auch schon bei der Männer-EM 2024, da haben wir ja noch damals eine Sendung gemacht, unter anderem zum Nationalismus, der rund um EM-Spiele stattgefunden hat. Und ich finde, das war eigentlich ein super Beispiel dafür, wie unterschiedlich man auf Fußball gucken kann. Denn du konntest eben über diese Brille, ja, hätte man sich zum Beispiel darüber freuen können, wenn gewisse Teams ausscheiden, damit dieses Thema eben einfach nicht mehr so wichtig wird oder dass auch gewisse, das protische bis autokratische Führungskräfte dann einen sportlichen Sieg nicht für ihre Agenda verwenden. Und trotzdem spürt man, aber wenn man dann vor allem in den Stadien ist, nicht nur die ehrliche Begeisterung, die erstmal nicht politisch motiviert sein muss, sondern einfach an diesem Sport entzündet ist. Und merkt es ja auch bei sich, dass man sich auch freut, mal über andere Teams, die weiterkommen. Also genau da hatten wir ja eigentlich schon diese Ambivalenz auch.
Voll.
Und das meinte ich auch so ein bisschen mit den Gleichzeitigkeiten. Also ich verstehe auch wirklich, ich habe vollstes Verständnis für jeden Menschen, der auch aufgrund der aktuellen Weltlage einfach bock hat, sich jetzt Fußball anzugucken und ein bisschen abzuschalten. Ich verstehe das, ich finde das total menschlich. Und gleichzeitig ist es eben trotzdem wichtig, da weiterhin kritisch drauf zu blicken. Und weil Eva das jetzt gerade mit den vielen Teilnehmerländern meinte, auch da kann man natürlich auf der einen Seite den ganzen Kommerzcenter kritisieren. Man kann aber auch sagen, hey, es sind so viele afrikanische Länder wie noch nie mit dabei, was ja lange Zeit so recht kritisiert wurde. Also ich glaube, es lohnt halt irgendwie echt bei diesen ganzen Themen mal zweimal hinzuschauen und vielleicht auch miteinander in den aktuellen Zeiten auch nicht so harsh zu sein, sondern das irgendwie auch, ja, wie du es gerade gesagt hast, Max, auch den Leuten zuzugestehen, dass sie einfach jetzt Bock haben, Fußball zu gucken. It's okay. So.
Ja, ja, aber bitte nochmal, Inga. Mein Problem ist, und das hast du jetzt leider nicht angesprochen, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich ansetzen soll. Also ich habe ja in unserem WhatsApp-Chat schon irgendwie darauf aufmerksam gemacht, ich mache Musik, ich schreibe Songs, ich produziere mit Studiemusikern und so weiter. Wenn ich das mache, da weiß ich, wo ich da hin will. Ich weiß nicht, wo ich bei dieser WM hin will.
Kannst du dich nicht treiben lassen, Jürgen.
Außer mit euch jetzt. Also das gibt mir nochmal ein bisschen mehr Halt. Wirklich, das sind richtige Menschen. Die sind auch liebenswürdig und klug. Da macht es Spaß, die jede Woche einmal zu treffen auf diesem virtuellen Weg. Da werden sich schon irgendwelche Krümel finden, sodass dieses Hänsel- und Gretel-Gefühl im Wald sich vielleicht abarbeiten lässt. Das ist eine Einladung an Inga, aber ich wollte nur noch erklären, im Moment ist meine Krücke, um da reinzukommen, dass ich mich für das englische Team interessiere. Oder die Brücke, irgendwo da rein. Weil da gibt es so Anhaltspunkte, wo ich sagen kann, guck mal, die müssten eigentlich, und dann haben sie einen deutschen Trainer, der ist ja nun auch nicht gerade nicht umstritten. Und da gibt es so alle möglichen Dinge, wo man so ein bisschen reinbeißen kann. Aber das ist möglicherweise auch eine völlige Fehleinschätzung von allem. Also Inga, ich wollte dich dies nicht abschneiden, aber ich glaube, ich kann dich richtig aufmunternd sagen. Hilf mir.
Ich verstehe dich.
Wo soll ich hingucken?
Ich verstehe, das ist sehr overwhelming aktuell, wenn man sich anguckt, wie es jetzt losgeht. Aber ich glaube, das Gute ist, wir reden ja in einer Woche wieder. Und ich glaube, wenn erst mal dieses Turnier angefangen hat, dann sortiert sich das vielleicht auch alles ein bisschen. Aber vielleicht sagen wir auch, in zwei Wochen ist immer noch alles overwhelming und man kann kaum folgen. Aber ich finde, so erfahrungsgemäß kristallisieren sich ja relativ schnell so ein paar Überraschungsspiele, ein paar sympathische Nationen raus und so weiter. Es ist auch ganz anders und wir sind immer noch in einer oder in zwei Wochen überfordert mit allem.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube schon, also meine persönliche Erfahrung ist, was mir persönlich fehlt, ist tatsächlich die Vorschau. Klingt jetzt paradox, weil ich mich selber dafür entschieden habe, sie nicht zu machen. Aber das war einfach nur Selbstschutz, weil ich hätte diesen Arbeitslast nicht stemmen können. Aber wenn du dich so in jedes Team reingräbst, dann findest du in jedem Team interessante Spiele und interessante Geschichten, Storylines, Narrative, wie auch immer du es nennen willst. Bei den großen Nationen, da hat man diesen offenen Schirm. Lionel Messi könnte Miro Klose überholen mit seinem WM-Torrekord. Wir haben zwei Spieler, die jetzt ihre sechste WM spielen könnten. Wir haben den immer gleichen mexikanischen Torhüter, der einfach immer nominiert wird. Und ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin gemeinsam mit ihm alt geworden. Aber einer von uns beiden ist komischerweise noch in Shape. Ich will nicht verraten, wer. Aber vor allem die kleinen Geschichten sind es dann eigentlich. Also ich weiß noch genau, wie ich mich in einem totalen Panama-Rabbit Hole verloren habe. Ich glaube, 2018 müsste das gewesen sein bei der Weltmeisterschaft. Und da kannte ich dann viel zu viele von diesen Spielern viel zu genau. Und das hilft einem natürlich. Und das ist auch ein bisschen das Traurige und ja auch das letztlich, Jürgen, was du dann auch merkst. Durch diese Vielzahl der Spiele ist es so ein bisschen random geworden. Also ein bisschen zufällig, wo man eigentlich als erstes hinguckt. Und deswegen war, also zumindest mir geht es so und ich habe auch den Eindruck, meine Umgebung auch, man weiß bei diesem Turnier sportlich noch gar nicht so viel. Man hat sich noch nicht eingestellt, wann sind eigentlich die Spiele. Die Anstoßzeiten sind auch komplett anders, als es mal versprochen wurde. Viel, viel schwieriger noch zu verfolgen. Und deswegen, wahrscheinlich brauchen wir alle so einen Anlauf. Die England-Brücke finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Ich bin auch einfach sehr gespannt auf aller Gastgeber, muss ich sagen. Das interessiert mich auch. Und dann wird es uns schon reingezogen haben, glaube ich.
Und sonst, Jürgen, hör dir einfach alle furchtbaren WM-Songs an und überleg, welchen du am schlimmsten findest. Und dann hast du schon mal einen Termin, einen Team, wo du hoffst, es fliegt ganz schnell drauf.
Den, den ich immer noch am schlimmsten finde, obwohl mein Freund Roman das jetzt nicht hören wird, ist der, den Erna zusammengekocht hat. Ich wollte ihm irgendwie helfen, ihn auch noch rauszubringen oder so. Aber wir haben beide nicht genug Zeit gefunden. Vielleicht wäre was draus geworden.
Also das heißt, du tust jetzt gerade einen unveröffentlichen WM-Song. Jürgen, das ist Next-Level-Marketing.
Leute, die nicht wissen, was ich so treibe und denen, dass ich das auch gerne dann mal rausgehe.
Stark.
Also wer eine Stunde 24 durchgehalten hat, wird jetzt belohnt.
So.
Ich weiß nicht. Also wenn Max jetzt noch hinten dran noch irgendwas aus meinem Archiv musikalisch draufschieben will, Jürgen, du darfst mir sehr gerne zu jeder Sendung hier was schicken und ich pack das einfach hinten dran.
Das ist dann das kleine Gudi für die höhere Noteurer.
Aber das wollte ich noch kurz ergänzen, ich weiß mehr über die WM-Songs der verschiedenen Länder und durch diesen furchtbaren WM-Song von Österreich kenne ich jetzt den österreichischen Karla. Ist doch super. Wollte ich nicht. Und es ist leider, aber ich muss sagen, also wenn es einer gewonnen hat und das ist für mich vielleicht so, du hast gesagt, Rabbitoil, wenn es so eine Side Story gibt, das ist für mich einfach Bosnien-Herzegowina. Ich finde, als die diesen WM-Einzug klargemacht haben, dieser Song, der mir die ganze Zeit in den Ohren schwebt, dann ist das einfach schon eine coole Sache. Und das gönnt man denen auch. Ich habe damals ganz viele Geschichten gesehen, auch von Menschen aus Bosnien, die inzwischen in Deutschland leben und so, und was das für die und ihre Familie bedeutet. Ich habe ja eben gesagt, ich kann es moralisch mit mir selber nicht vereinbaren, da hinreisen zu wollen oder so. Ich weiß aber auch gleichzeitig, ich bin ja schon lange Teillein des korrupten Fußballsystems. So kann ich auch verstehen, wenn jeder sagt so, ach Damen, ziehst du jetzt die Grenze. Also, ne? Check ich alles, also Krauthöne meinte Inga, glaube ich, eben schon ganz wichtig. Aber ja, also ich bin auch gespannt, wie wir da in einer Woche nochmal drauf gucken. Und dann ist ja auch, also dann haben wir ja noch schon schön die Side Story. Jürgen hat es, glaube ich, eben schon mal angekündigt, der Oktagon im Rasen des Weißen Hauses zu Donald Trumps 80. Geburtstag. Super schön. Super toll. Freuen wir uns alle drauf.
Es hilft jetzt auch gerade nicht unbedingt, dass der eine von uns in der Runde, der alles weiß, so die wir in Sportlich gesehen, dass der nicht mit dabei ist. Weil ansonsten hätte Tobi uns jetzt schon 13 gute Wissensnagelzinnen geschmissen. Aber ja, vielleicht wird auch der eine oder andere Autokorso dann auch hierzulande in Deutschland noch dazu führen. Die Türkei hat alle ihre Spiele nachts oder sehr früh am Morgen. Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, wie sich das dann auswirkt.
Aber Stichwort Tobi, wenn ich das noch sagen darf. Du weißt ja, als alter Magazinfahrensmann, man muss auch irgendwie gucken, dass man steigert. Man kann nicht alle Höhepunkte gleich am Anfang abfacken. Also Tobis Einstieg nächste Woche wird ein Highlight. Also freut euch drauf, weil endlich kommt Kompetenz in den Laden.
Der wird uns sagen, das hätte ich euch letzte Woche alles schon sagen können. Aber auch da, genau, also auch da Schottland auch sehr, sehr cool. Ich finde nachher, wenn man so ein bisschen EM 2024 verfolgt hat, haben ja viele auch irgendwie Schottland so ein bisschen lieben gelernt. Vielleicht ist es dann so, wenn man irgendwie Bock hat, auf so ein paar Side-Stories zu gucken. Das ist jetzt wirklich nur ein emotionaler Faktor. Aber ich habe ja durch den Nationalteams-Suite gestern, durch Martin Raffelt, glaube ich, gelernt, dass Ecuador eine gute Defensive hat oder so. Also hier.
Eine sehr gute Defensive.
So, hört dich von. Also ja.
Also Side-Stories, Ted Lasso kommt zurück.
So. Jetzt hast du Eva gerade mit einem riesigen Lasse über den Teich gezogen.
Für solche Sachen erzähle ich euch gerne beim nächsten Mal mehr. Und wenn wir nicht gestorben sind.
Sehr gut. Und ich werde noch einen interessanten Artikel zur Österreich-WM-Song-Hin-und-Her-Posse packen, wenn ihr es noch nicht gelesen habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das lohnt sich. Aber mit Schottland sind wir indirekt auch schon bei einem weiteren Thema gelandet. Denn ich habe ein Video gesehen, da wurden unter anderem schottische Fans befragt. Ich glaube von den New York Times. Muss ich noch mal nachgucken, von wem das Video eigentlich war. Nämlich zu den Fragen, ob sie eigentlich WM-Tickets haben und wie viel sie ausgezahlt haben oder wie viel sie bezahlen hätten müssen, um in ein Stadion zu kommen. Man konnte da mannigfaltige schottische Flüche hören über die Ticketpreise. Da sind wir nämlich bei einem weiteren ganz großen Thema dieser Weltmeisterschaft. Auf der einen Seite haben wir einen Ticketmarkt, der angeblich komplett leer gefegt ist. Also die FIFA hat schon sehr, sehr früh von Millionen Ticketanfragen gesprochen. Gleichzeitig sind auch Resale-Plattformen zum Teil mit wahnsinnigen Ticketpreis- steigerungen bestückt und die FIFA kassiert hier jedes Mal doppelt. Also sowohl, wenn ein Ticket wiederverkauft wird auf der FIFA Resale-Plattform, dann bekommt die FIFA sowohl vom Käufer als auch vom Verkäufer 15 Prozent und profitiert deshalb auch extrem davon, wenn eben zum Beispiel Final-Tickets für, also es gibt sogar zwei, die gerade drinstehen, für 2,3 Millionen US-Dollar. Ich hoffe, die gehen nicht weg. Also das ist auf der einen Seite die eine Realität, sehr, sehr hohe Ticketpreise und wahnsinnig viel Geld, was bei der FIFA ankommen sollte. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir aber auch gerade bei nicht so begehrten Spielen den dringenden Verdacht, hier sind noch jede Menge Tickets zu bekommen. Und es sieht sogar auch so aus, als ob die FIFA selbst diese Tickets auf Reseller-Plattformen jetzt anbietet. Nicht mehr über die offizielle FIFA-Seite, sondern dann kannst du die eben woanders dann, ja, interessanterweise ganze Reihen an Tickets sind da eben frei. Und der Verdacht liegt sehr nahe, die FIFA hat da ihre Tickets nicht wegbekommen. Und das, Inga, haben wir ja beim Club-Weltmeisterschaftsbeispiel ja schon mal gesehen. Und da war es am Ende so, ich glaube, das billigste Ticket ging dann für 11 Dollar weg oder waren es sogar 7 US-Dollar. Also wie blickst du denn auf dieses Thema, was ja schon wieder komplett ambivalent ist? Einmal hier die ganz hohen Preise und hohe Nachfrage und wenig Angebot. Auf der anderen Seite offenbar genau das Gegenteil.
Ja, also genau, bei der Club-WM, daran musste ich auch sofort denken. Da war das ja letztes Jahr so, dass dann das eine Halbfinale-Ticket das günstigste irgendwie von über 400 Dollar auf, ich glaube, ja, wie du gesagt hast, 11, 13 irgendwie so runtergefallen ist. Die FIFA framed das dann als, ja, ich glaube, dynamische Preisgestaltung. Das wäre auch ein schöner Euphemismus. Naja, es klingt immer so ein bisschen so, als würde die FIFA, die Fußballfans selbst irgendwie hassen, wenn man sich die Ticketpreise anguckt, wenn man sich diesen intransparenten Umgang anschaut, wenn man sich anschaut, dass bis vor kurzem bei über 40 Grad keine Wasserflaschen an den Stadien zugelassen werden sollten. Also das spricht irgendwie sehr für sich. Ich finde halt, was irgendwie alles so ein bisschen eint in diesem Vorgehen, dass es völlig intransparent ist. Es wird nicht als nötig empfunden, den Fans überhaupt irgendwas zu erklären, sondern die werden mit ganz schwer versteckt in der App oder schwer verständlichen Erklärungen so allein gelassen. Es ist ja sogar mittlerweile so, dass die Generalstaatsanwältinnen in den USA ermitteln, was ja auch schon zeigt, wie brisant diese ganze Geschichte ist. Ja, und ich meine, es ist irgendwie offensichtlich. Nur die FIFA will halt vermeiden, dass da nachdem Gianni Infantino die größte und tollste WM aller Zeiten versprochen hat, dass da leere Ränge sind. Und arbeitet dann eben so mit künstlicher Verknappung, mit in der Hoffnung, dass die dann ganz schnell anfangs weggehen und jetzt bleiben sie eben drauf sitzen. Und ich finde es schon auch erstaunlich, oder nicht erstaunlich, aber bemerkenswert zu sehen, wie viel Beschwerden, wie viel Unzufriedenheit sich gerade auch so bei den Fans in den sozialen Medien zum Beispiel regt. Also das ärgert schon zu Recht ganz schön viele.
Kleine Beobachtung nur da rein, Entschuldigung, Eva, du hast dich, glaube ich, gemeldet.
Alles gut.
Ein Teil von dem Problem dieser WM ist die unglaubliche Größe der Stadien, die man ausgewählt hat. Und gleichzeitig hat man ganz viele Mannschaften, für die sich relativ wenig Menschen erstmal interessieren. Die müsste man also als casual oder peripheral oder als Leute bezeichnen, die man richtig wach machen muss, damit sie da überhaupt hinwollen oder so. Und gleichzeitig, und das ist der Grund für meine Anmerkung, gleichzeitig gibt es wunderbare Fußballstadien in den USA. An den neuen Datums, also Fassungsvermögen 20.000 bis 25.000 Zuschauer, die nur für Fußball gebaut worden sind, die für solche Spiele wunderbar geeignet wären. Nur darauf scheint keiner gekommen zu sein, bei der FIFA oder auch bei den Ausrichterverbänden, wie man das zum Beispiel vernünftig ausmendelt. Das wäre auch Dynamic Pricing. Das ist ja abgeguckt von den Fluggesellschaften, die das schon seit Jahr und Tag machen. Aber die haben dann auch die Möglichkeit, mal ein kleineres Flugzeug zu nehmen, wenn die Nachfrage nachgelassen hat. Oder sie könnten auch gucken, ob sie nicht vielleicht noch eine große alte 747 aus dem Stall holen, um mehr Leute zu transportieren. Diese Inflexibilität ist ein unglaublich interessanter Teil, wenn auch unsinnlich, aber ein interessanter Teil dieser verbaselten Art, solche Veranstaltungen zu machen.
Ich wollte noch einmal ergänzend sagen, es ist diese ganzen hohen Preise und so. Infantino hat das ja begründet. Oder generell die FIFA auch, in denen man gesagt hat, ja, also in Amerika zahlen die Leute ja sowieso total viel Geld für Sporting-Events und Konzerte und Co. Was schonmal, finde ich, sehr lustig ist, weil wir haben eben darüber gesprochen, ganz am Anfang, dass vor allem der Männerfußball in den USA ja gar nicht so viel Zuspruch hat. Und eigentlich, wenn ich zum Beispiel als FIFA neue ZuschauerInnen erschließen wollen würde, ganz leichte Marketing-Sprech in dem Sinne, versuche ich ja Leute anzulocken, zum Beispiel durch den Unterschied, dass die Preise günstiger sind, indem ich sage, hier guck mal, der Fußball ist so toll, geht dahin, Preise sind günstiger. Und dann ist es sehr lustig. Und Inga, ich habe extra nachgeguckt, ich musste einmal, wenn wir zusammen in einem Podcast sitzen, ich musste einmal das Rift heulen kriegen, weil zum Beispiel ja gerade damals, als die Arras Tour Tickets online gingen, im Anschluss gab es ein Verfahren, das jetzt glaube ich Anfang dieses Jahres beendet wurde, gegen Ticketmaster bzw. Live Nation, wegen Monopolstellung, weil eben Fans alleine das eben ein Anbieter so viel Macht hat und da eben auch dieses Dynamic Pricing drin war und so, dagegen haben ja viele Fans einfach geklagt. Und deshalb ist es sehr, sehr lustig, wie wenig man den Markt kennt, auf dem man sich beruht. Das wollte ich da immer noch einbringen. Und ja, es ist einfach, also das war damals unter der beiden Regierungen. Natürlich hat Deutschland nicht gegen Live Nation wegen Monopolstellung geklagt. Das können wir uns auch irgendwie alle denken. Aber das eben auch nochmal, wie sehr die das verkannt haben. Und ich glaube, Jürgen hat es eben schon mal gesagt. Natürlich, was Infantino immer sagt, wenn irgendwo viel Kohle drin steckt. Ja, das wird alles reinvestiert in den Fußball und überall. Und wir wollen euch ja nur stärken. Und ja, also komplett absurd, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, andererseits, was dagegen spricht, dass man nicht so ganz genau wusste, was man da tut, ist, die FIFA achtet sehr genau darauf, eben nicht vom Dynamic Pricing zu sprechen. Sie sprechen immer vom Variable Pricing.
Nein, nein.
Das ist doch die offizielle.
Entschuldigung, Infantino hat, ich hab die Töne, die ich dir schicken kann. Infantino hat sich schon längst auf diesen Begriff festgelegt, Dynamic Pricing.
Ja, in den AGB und so weiter steht es aber anders, weil das nämlich auch tatsächlich Teil der Ermittlungen ist, der Staatsanwaltschaften da in New Jersey und New York. Weil Variables Pricing würde eben bedeuten, du passt es schrittweise immer wieder an Dynamic ist eben quasi dann so ein letztlich algorithmisch funktionierendes System, was dann eben nach oben hin auch letztlich gar keine Grenzen hat. Und dagegen wollte sich die FIFA, nach dem was ich gelesen hatte, auch juristisch durchaus absichern. Was aber das große Problem war, neben dem ganzen Marketing sprech, also das kann man ja alles weglassen. Es ist jetzt erstmal egal, wie viele Millionen Ticketanfragen sie eigentlich hatten und ob sie es jetzt einfach nur nicht hinbekommen haben, diese Tickets loszubekommen oder ob das eine Lüge war. Aber das Interessante ist, in wie vielen Punkten die Käuferinnen und Käufer im Umklaren gelassen wurden und wie viele Dinge immer durch AGB abgesichert, aber letztlich sich noch verändert haben. Also sprich, wir haben Erfahrungsberichte von Fans, die haben in einer Kategorie ein Ticket gekauft und im Nachhinein wurden dann aber ihnen andere Tickets, andere Sitzplätze in dieser Kategorie angeboten und sie haben sich nicht verbessert, um es sozusagen zu sagen, sondern sie haben dann schlechtere Plätze bekommen. Zum Teil wurden ganze Kategorien geändert. Zum Teil war es so, dass Käuferinnen und Käufer Tickets gekauft haben und erst mit der Zahlungsaufforderung den Preis zum ersten Mal gesehen haben, den sie dafür bezahlen sollen. Also es ist eben neben allen Dingen, die mit Angebot und Nachfrage noch zu tun haben könnten, ein extrem seltsamer Prozess, ein intransparenter Prozess, der ja auch letztlich deshalb Angriffspunkte überhaupt bietet zu eben solchen Ermittlungen, die ja letztlich auf Betrug hinauslaufen. Also dass man eben versucht, die Käuferinnen und Käufer bewusst zu täuschen und dem unklaren zu lassen, um eben noch mehr Geld dabei herauszuholen. Eva, du wolltest noch was ergänzen.
Genau. Bevor nämlich, also erstens ist es sehr ungewöhnlich überhaupt gewesen, wie spät die FIFA kommuniziert hat, wann man, also wann es diese Tickets gibt. Und also wenn man es vergleicht zum Beispiel mit Russland, das war fast zwei Jahre vorher, wo man genau wusste, wann beginnt welcher Verkaufsstart. Und bevor es ja überhaupt diese Tickets gab, gab es ja noch ja natürlich Krypto mit zusammen mit so einer Kryptowährung quasi. Also es hieß dann ein digitaler Right-to-Buy-Token, der selber Hunderte von Dollar kostete. Und die FIFA hat davon über 30.000 verkauft. Und das war ein Versprechen, dass BesitzerInnen dieses Tokens ein bis zwei Tickets für ein später bekanntes Datum, für einen später bekannten Preis kaufen können. Und auch da, also damit müssen die Millionen von Dollar eingenommen haben. Aber das war eben auch noch der Punkt, der überhaupt vor dem Ticketverkauf losging. Also auch komplett absurd.
Inga?
Was ich aber ganz lustig fand, vor ein paar Tagen hatte ich dann gesehen, dass irgendwie aus Versehen Tickets kostenlos über die Plattformen rausgegeben wurden. Und die Fans wurden aber natürlich danach darauf festgenagelt, sie mussten das zahlen, wo ich mich auch gefragt habe. Also mussten die Fans quasi über 2000 Euro für Tickets zahlen, die sie vielleicht gar nicht haben wollten, im Zweifel. Denn ich habe an dem Tag aus Recherchegründen mich auch auf dieser Plattform angemeldet und mir dann schon vorgestellt, dass ich jetzt plötzlich über 2000 Euro für so ein Ticket für ein Spiel zahlen muss. Einfach weil da dieser Fehler der FIFA unterlaufen war. Das war sehr skurril.
Viel Spaß, das in der Spesenabteilung des Tagesspiegels einzureichen. Tatsächlich muss man aber auch sagen, also die FIFA steht auch, ich möchte es kein Mitleid schüren, aber sie steht unter einem finanziellen Druck. Also dieses Turnier war immer schon das Turnier, mit dem am meisten Geld verdient werden sollte. Zwischen 12 und 13 Milliarden US-Dollar möchte die FIFA einnehmen. Das ist Schätzungen nach das Doppelte als das, was man hätte einnehmen können, wenn diese WM in Marokko stattgefunden hätte. Auch das dürfte einer der Gründe gewesen sein, warum diese WM an Kanada, Mexiko und die USA eben ging. Gleichzeitig hat man zwar in vielen Teilen der Welt positive TV-Verträge abgeschlossen, aber ausgerechnet für den US-Markt hat man einen sehr, sehr schlechten Deal gemacht. Das lag an der Verschiebung der WM in Qatar, dadurch, dass die in den Winter verschoben wurde, was für Fox Sports, das damals sich die Rechte gesichert hatte an der WM, eine deutliche Verschlechterung der Rechte vermeintlich bedeutet hätte, weil man dann in Konkurrenz zu vielen US-Sportarten noch gestanden hätte, die dann eben noch im laufenden Liga-Betrieb waren. Hat man damals, bevor man diese Verschiebung gemacht hat, einen Monat vorher, hat Fox für wirklichen Schnapper letztlich die TV-Rechte auch für dieses Turnier hier bekommen. Im Nachhinein hat sich rausgestellt, die Quoten von Fox waren super. Und das, was die FIFA jetzt von Fox Sports bekommt, das sind 450 Millionen US-Dollar, ist nach Schätzung zur Folge wahrscheinlich nur so 50 Prozent ungefähr des Wertes dieser TV-Rechte an diesem Heimturnier, dass das eigentlich gegeben hätte. Also natürlich teilweise nur Heimturnier. Man rechnet eigentlich also...
Sonderfall, Entschuldigung, Max, Sonderfall. Normalerweise werden solche Rechte-Deals ausgeschrieben. Und der Sonderfall war, dass man diese Art von Auktion für diese WM ausgeblendet hat. Und dass es da auch intern bei der FIFA niemanden gab, der sagt, Leute, was machen wir eigentlich? Was für eine Kaskade. Erst wird den Kataris das Ding gegeben, dann wird ihnen erlaubt, dass sie das einfach verschieben können in eine etwas bessere Klimaphase des Jahres. Und dann wird auch noch hinten bei Fox irgendwie gespart oder so. Weil ISBN war wirklich heiß auf diese WM und die Rechte. Und die hätten auch das, was du gerade so ein bisschen rausgearbeitet hast, die hätten das auch bezahlt. Und die hätten auch was daraus gemacht aus diesem Ereignis. Das ist nämlich ein wirklich viel besserer Sport-Fernsehaberat als dieses Fox-Gedöns. Und auch dort, ich meine, ich erinnere mich noch an, als das so hoch blubberte, es gab niemanden, der irgendwie gesagt hat, Leute, wie viele Eigentore können wir uns hier eigentlich leisten?
Ja, vor allem, also die Umstände sind immer noch ungeklärt, wie eigentlich auch Fox dazu kam, dass sie, also ESPN hatte sowohl die Rechte 94 als dann auch die 2014. Die Rechte vorher, die wurden gar nicht verkauft im US-Markt, die hatte dann trotzdem ESPN, aber sie mussten nicht dafür zahlen, zeigt auch die Entwicklung, die das Interesse am Fußball genommen hat in den USA. Aber Fox lag ganz knapp über dem Angebot von ESPN. Damals involviert war Jerome Walke, der wurde später unter anderem für zehn Jahre von der Ethikkommission der FIFA gesperrt, weil er WM-Tickets überteuert verkauft hatte. Und es wurde ihm auch in Beteiligung am Stimmenkauf 2011 und 2015 schon vorgeworfen. Also das ist quasi schon der erste Punkt, wie kam Fox eigentlich dann an diese Rechte und dann eben genau das, was du sagst. Ohne jede Ausschreibung würde einfach dieser Vertrag nochmal verlängert, um ein Turnier, um eben möglicher Kritik oder gar einer Klage zu begegnen. Die Fox hätte vielleicht anstrengen können. Fox hat ansonsten auch nicht nur von den Quoten profitiert, sondern Qatar hat auch bemerkenswert viel Werbung während der WM-Berichterstattung 2022 bei Fox geschaltet. Gleichzeitig hatte Fox das größte Studio vor Ort in Qatar, das nach allem, was man weiß, auch in Teilen gar nicht von Fox selbst bezahlt wurde, sondern das hat da der katarische Staatsfonds dann hingestellt für Umme und dafür gab es dann eigentlich auch keine kritische Berichterstattung. Also es war das perfekte Konglomerat, aber was ich damit nur herleiten wollte, war diese WM, sie wird ein wirtschaftlicher Erfolg werden. Gianni Infantino wird natürlich auch danach sagen, beste WM aller Zeiten und so weiter und so fort, aber er steht unter einigem Druck. Das haben wir schon bei der FIFA Club WM gesehen. Da hat man Saudi-Arabien gebraucht, die für einen völlig irrsinnigen Preis von einer Milliarde US-Dollar die TV-Rechte gekauft haben und dann die bei The Zone gezeigt wurden. Übrigens, bei The Zone kann man jetzt alle FIFA-Plus-Inhalte sehen. FIFA Plus selbst existiert in dieser Form nicht mehr. Ein Schelm, wer da eine Verbindung herstellt. Ich habe es jetzt auch nur rein zufällig nacheinander genannt. Aber bei diesem Turnier ist es eben auch so. Und gleichzeitig, wenn man sich die steuerrechtlichen Gegebenheiten ansieht, also in den USA weitgehend steuerfrei, sämtliche Einnahmen für die FIFA, auch in Mexiko und Kanada sehr positiv, also mit wenig steuerbedingter Einnahmen, dann ist wahrscheinlich dieses Turnier auch dasjenige, was sich zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt noch am besten monetarisieren lässt für die FIFA, die ja tatsächlich nur alle vier Jahre die Möglichkeit hat, eben ihren Etat letztlich, den sie ja dann zu 87 Prozent an die Mitgliedsverbände verteilt und womit man sich die Wiederwahl sichern kann als Person Gianni Infantino, auch nur alle vier Jahre die Möglichkeit hat, dieses Geld einzunehmen. Also da ist Druck drauf. Und ich glaube, dass man das halt zumindest mal erwähnt haben muss, wenn man eben über diese WM-Ticket-Sache spricht, wo wir eben auf der einen Seite eben sehen, die FIFA nimmt eben Fans aus. Natürlich auf einen Markt, der auch anders tickt. Also ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel auch eine eine Berechnung gesehen für New York Knicks-Fans. Wir hatten es ja vorhin schon von Spiel 3 in der Finest Series. Da hat jemand ausgerechnet, wie viel würde es kosten, eben ein Spiel sich in New York, im Madison Square Garden anzugucken, im Vergleich dazu zu den Spurs nach Antonio zu fliegen. Und dort eben ein Spiel zu gucken. Am Ende der Geschichte ist es so, du hättest dir auswärts das Spiel angucken können und hättest sogar noch 2000 Dollar gespart, mit Flug und Übernachtung, eben im Vergleich zu den Ticketpreisen, die es da im Madison Square Garden gab.
Kleine Sonderanmerkung, die Tickets sind alle weg, das sind alles Jahresgarten. Das heißt, es ist sowieso immer ein Secondary Market. Und auf dem Markt passieren dann eben je nach aktueller Entwicklung solche Dinge. Und San Antonio ist eine relativ kleine Stadt, also da im Vergleich zu New York und Chicago und Los Angeles. Und da lässt sich vielleicht auch mal schneller jemand mit ein paar Hundert Dollar abspeisen und gibt sein Ticket weiter. Das ist in New York, da sind die Leute ein bisschen schlauert auf. Also die sagen dann nicht. Aber wenn die alle das gewusst hätten, die das jetzt verkauft haben, dass, was sie, wenn sie das nicht verkauft haben, wir jetzt dahin müssen heute Abend, was da auf sich zukommt, vielleicht hätten sie dann auch für einen niedrigen Preis abgegeben.
Wenn ich noch einen Artikel empfehlen darf, also wer so diese ganze Ticketgeschichte noch mal durchlesen will, die The Athletic hat einen sehr schönen Artikel dazu veröffentlicht, der heißt The 2026 World Cup Ticket Saga Explain from start to almost finish. Kann ich sehr empfehlen. Fand ich tatsächlich auch sehr schlüssig, aufgearbeitet gerade mit diesen ganzen Phasen. Kann ich sehr gut strukturiert empfehlen.
Und vielleicht noch eine ergänzende, werde ich dann auch verlinken, einen Artikel, der das beschreibt. In Mexiko im Aztekenstadion haben wir die schöne Situation, dass damals in den 60ern, als das Bau des Stadions gebaut wurde, den Betreibern das Geld ausging. Deswegen haben sie damals 600 Logen und 800 Sitzplätze an dann wohlhabendere Fußballfans verkauft und zwar für das Recht, auf 99 Jahre hin, also bis 2065, alle Events in diesem Stadion kostenlos besuchen zu dürfen. Das hat die FIFA vor große Probleme gestellt. Ehrlicherweise, weil sie auch davon ausgegangen sind, na das kann ja nicht für die WM auch gelten. Und die Lojenbesitzer dann mit mexikanischen Gerichten gesagt haben, nö doch, eigentlich schon. Und jetzt musste man die da irgendwie noch unterbekommen. Also das vielleicht noch als...
Ich glaube die lateinische Formule, Pacta sunt servanda. Oder Pacta servanda sunt, ich weiß nicht genau.
Nee, sunt servanda ist, glaub ich richtig.
Hat nur das kleine Latinum, ich kann das also jetzt nicht genau. Das ist ein anderer.
Gut, also das ist das Ticket-Thema. Ich denke, wir werden es besprechen. Lasst uns noch ganz kurz ein Thema zumindest ansprechen, das die Hörerinnen und Hörer eben auch mitbekommen haben. Wir haben zwei Streikgebaren, die sich auf die WM auswirken konnten. Das eine haben wir vorhin schon mal angesprochen. Das hat Jürgen schon erwähnt. Das ist die Gewerkschaft des SoFi-Stadiums in Inglewood, Kalifornien. Also das ist das Stadion, in dem die Los Angeles, die Chargers und die Rams spielen. So ist es korrekt. Die haben mit 96 Prozent dafür gestimmt, eben dass sie in Streik gehen können. Sie behandeln, verhandeln gerade mit dem Betreiber eben. Zum einen wollen sie höhere Löhne und zum anderen geht es eben um das Recht, den Arbeitsplatz zu verlassen. Sollte ICE irgendwelche Festnahmen unter den Beschäftigten verführen. Und das zweite Thema, das ist auch noch nicht, glaube ich, so in ganz großen Medien gelandet, spielt sich in Mexiko ab. Dort ist es so, dass aktuell die Fanplaza in Mexiko City, die wird von Lehrkräften besetzt. Die haben zum Teil meterhohe Fußball-Statuen, die dort errichtet waren, zum Einsturz gebracht und dann mit ihren Forderungen gesprüht. Und die Forderungen standen, die hieß dann auch direkt, also hier findet, hier wird kein Ball rollen, solange wir keine Lösung gefunden haben für unsere Probleme. Inga, ich habe dich schon nicken sehen und ich habe ja auch schon jetzt mitbekommen, dass ihr ja auch Mexiko genauer im Blick habt. Was muss man denn da zu deiner Meinung nach wissen und wie bewertest du das, was da passiert?
Was man genau dazu wissen muss, liest man am Dienstagmorgen im Tagesspiel.
Teasing next level, ich sehe schon.
Nein, ich finde das sehr bemerkenswert. Also diese Bilder von den riesigen Fußballfiguren, die da mit Seilen zu Boden gezogen werden, das sind schon irgendwie krasse Bilder. Die Trikots, die im Brand gesteckt werden. Ich glaube, was man daraus so mitnehmen kann, ist, dass gerade die Probleme des Landes, die eben die breite Bevölkerung treffen, einfach sehr viel präsenter für die Menschen sind, sehr viel relevanter sind als dieses Fußballturnier. Ich hatte vor ein paar Monaten mit einigen Menschen in Mexiko gesprochen, Monterey zum Beispiel, die auch gesagt haben, sie wollen A, diese Aufmerksamkeit dieses Großturniers jetzt nutzen, um ihre Anliegen eben auf der großen globalen Bühne vorzubringen, um dafür Aufmerksamkeit zu schaffen. Und B, es ist für sie auch einfach, es haben zumindest die Menschen, berichtet mir, nicht gesprochen, aber auch einfach absurd bei all den Versprechungen, die die Regierung gemacht hat, beispielsweise was die Infrastruktur angeht, mit Blick auf das Turnier, dass jetzt so viel Geld da rein fließt, während gleichzeitig eben Leute in Großstädten kommen, zur Arbeit kommen, weil die Infrastruktur so marode ist. Also, was ja auch immer noch ein großes Thema ist, werden wir auch vielleicht in den nächsten Wochen mal drüber sprechen, diese vielen vermissten Menschen in Mexiko, die jetzt auch Thema sind.
130.000 muss man dazu sagen.
130.000 muss man sich wirklich mal vor Augen, kann man sich kaum vor Augen führen. Die Probleme, die das Land hat, die die Menschen dort haben, sind einfach drängender und größer als jetzt dieses Gigatonier.
Schon im März gab es da eine Protestaktion. Da wurde ein Fußballfeld auf einer Autobahn aufgezeichnet. Und die Protestierenden haben dort Fußballspiele veranstaltet und damit logischerweise den kompletten Verkehr lahmgelegt, um eben dagegen zu protestieren, dass die WM die eigentlichen Probleme des Landes überdeckt. Wir werden da auch auf jeden Fall im Tribünengespräch noch mal näher drauf eingehen, auch auf diese irre Zahl der 130.000. Jetzt ist aber ja dann die Frage, Jürgen, mit deiner Erfahrung von Weltmeisterschaften, wie sehr, glaubst du, wird das wirklich beeinträchtigen? Du hast vorhin schon mal vom GAU gesprochen, als du eben von einem möglichen Streik der Stradionbeschäftigten in Inglewood, Kalifornien gesprochen hast. Acht WM-Spiele würden dort stattfinden. In Mexiko haben wir natürlich jetzt auch einige. Glaubst du, wir werden da noch mal aktuell darüber sprechen in den nächsten Wochen?
Ja, aber mehr darüber, wie das dann doch irgendwie gerade gebogen wird. Also die Erfahrungen mit diesem Land sind so, dass also viele Sachen nicht wirklich am Anfang so aussehen, als ob sie funktionieren würden. Und wenn man hier lebt, dann gewöhnt man sich auch so einen gewissen Skeptizismus an und fast eine Paranoia, dass man immer davon ausgeht, dass Sachen nicht am Ende nicht funktionieren. Das ist aber eine gute Vorbereitung darauf, dass man auf die Events und Abas irgendwie eingehen kann und am Ende stellt sich halt raus, sonst würden wir hier auch nicht leben, würden wir hier wieder auswandern. Dass es dann doch irgendwie funktioniert. Nur, das kostet auch. Also dieses System hier, dieses Verhalten der Leute, die Bereitschaft, Dinge noch irgendwie möglich zu machen und so, das kostet an Stellen, die dann nicht so ohne weiteres auf dem Tisch liegen in einer normalen Buchhaltung oder so. Das sind soziale Kosten, das sind auch kommerzielle Kosten, das Stichwort haben wir ja gerade gesprochen. Fox, nur dann, bitte, das kriegen die halt weniger. Also im Fußball finde ich auch noch bemerkenswert, also wie Beckham damals mit dieser Billigprämie angelockt wurde, dass er, wenn er dann mal irgendwann soweit ist und ein eigenes Team auf die Beine stellen möchte, dann braucht er bloß 25 Millionen Dollar aufzutreiben, zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo man also schon 500 Millionen aufgerufen hatte oder so. Also diese, die Dinge werden irgendwie gerade gezogen und werden irgendwie hinbekommen und werden über geschickte Art, wo die Medien auch immer so ein bisschen Cheerleader und Propagandisten sind und so tun als, ja, also es gibt einige Medien, die auch genauer hingucken, aber andere, die immer mehr auf diese Oberfläche abfahren. Und dann wird davon auch nicht mehr so viel geredet. Also wenn dann mal Messi wirklich da auftaucht und spielt oder zusammen mit den Argentinern und die anderen großen bekannten Spieler, verändert das die Wahrnehmung der Fußballleihen, der Beobachter und so. Und dann wird man auch erkennen, dass einiges von dem, was jetzt so schief liegt, auch irgendwie wieder repariert worden ist.
Aber glaubst du das auch für das in Mexiko, für die Zustände dort? Also um kurz die Dimension klarzumachen. Wir haben zum einen da sowieso eine innenpolitisch extrem aufgeheizte Lage inklusive eben 130.000 vermisster Menschen aktuell. Aber wenn man sich die Forderungen der Lehrkräfte anguckt, die fordern 100 Prozent mehr Gehalt. Das klingt jetzt wahnsinnig raffgierig, aber sie kommen von einem sehr niedrigen Lohnniveau. Die Regierung hatte ihnen 20 Prozent gewährt und später dann mit einer konkurrierenden Gewerkschaft 23 Prozent herausgehandelt. Und aber Scheinborn hat sich da sehr eindeutig geäußert, hat gesagt, also mehr ist einfach aktuell nicht möglich. Das liegt da so weit auseinander, dass man kann sich natürlich vorstellen, dass hier durch Repressionen die vertrieben werden von diesen entsprechenden öffentlichen Orten. Und es wurde ja auch schon Tränengas eingesetzt gegen Protestierende. Gleichzeitig gab es auch schon Ausschreitungen, wo man allerdings auch nicht ganz genau weiß, ob da wirklich auch die Lehrkräfte für verantwortlich waren. Das hat auch die Präsidentin selbst gesagt, dass sie davon eigentlich nicht ausgeht. Aber man liegt da schon sehr weit auseinander. Also ich würde dir beim Streik der Beschäftigten im SoFi-Stadium, da würde ich dir Recht geben. Das ist eine Frage, da kannst du Geld auf dieses Problem draufschmeißen. Und die Stadionbetreiber haben dieses Geld eigentlich. Sie wollen es nur einfach nicht rausgeben. In Mexiko ist die Lage ja dann vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen schwerer aufzulösen.
Ja, aber du hattest mich nach meiner Erfahrung gefragt. Und ich habe, also mit Mexiko ist fast ein blinder Fleck. Also ich bin da nur einmal kurz knapp über die Grenze gefahren für eine Geschichte, die ich gemacht habe südlich von Texas. Ich habe mich also wirklich nur am Rande mit Mexiko beschäftigt und hätte auch jetzt gar keinen Stoff, um über das, was du gerade gesagt hast, hinaus zu sagen, ja, dies oder das. Also ich finde es auch gut, dass du das einbringst. Aber ich glaube, vielleicht hat einer von den beiden Damen hier.
Na, Inga wird uns ja sagen, was morgen im Tagesschwiegel steht.
Ne, eben nicht. Ich glaube, Sie verknappt ihn.
Vielleicht lohnt es da auch mal ein bisschen abzuwarten, wie es jetzt im Endeffekt sich noch so weiterentwickelt. Ich meine, wir sitzen hier, also ich sitze sehr weit weg. Eva auch, Jürgen nicht ganz so weit weg, aber da nochmal ein paar Tage dem, glaube ich, Zeit zu geben und zu schauen, wie da so die Weiterentwicklung ist. Ich finde es jetzt auch ein bisschen schwierig, da so eine Prognose zu wagen.
Und es gibt eine historische Parallele, aber auf die jetzt abzuziehen, das ist wirklich nicht redlich. Also vor den Olympischen Spielen 1968, da wurde das Militär eingesetzt und Studenten sind dabei umgekommen bei ihren Demonstrationen, um diese im Grunde zufällige Olympische, diese Olympischen Spiele, die ihnen zufällig in den Schoß gefallen sind, irgendwie doch auf die Beine zu stellen. Also damit rechne ich jetzt nicht, aber das ist auch zumindest historisch etwas, woran sich vielleicht die Leute, die dort jetzt auch Militärs einsetzen, befehlen können, auch erinnern und fragen, wie krass oder wie hart gehen wir jetzt vor?
Ich glaube, es wird einfach nur angekündigt, jetzt schon, dass man halt die Polizei und Sicherheitspräsenz rund um dieses Fan-Festival, eine Socalo-Plaza da eben in Mexiko City erhöhen wollen wird, eben aufgrund dieser Proteste. Aber zum Beispiel, Scheinbaum will halt selber da das Eröffnungsspiel gucken, weil sie halt ihr Ticket verschenkt hat, an eine 21-Jährige oder ein indigenous woman verschenkt hat für das Eröffnungsspiel. Das heißt, sie wird halt eben auch nicht im Stadion sein, sondern will dieses Spiel eben selber auf dieser Plaza gucken.
100.000 Sicherheitskräfte militärs sollen eingesetzt werden in Mexiko, um die Spiele abzusichern. Die Ironie des Tages war, dass während ich gerade nochmal diesen Punkt genauer vorbereitet habe, kam dann die E-Mail von der FIFA mit dem betreffend größtes Rahmenprogramm der Turniergeschichte in den WM-Spielorten und sie haben nochmal auf sehr, sehr vielen Worten, mit sehr vielen Silben nochmal drüber gesprochen, dass es die größten und tollsten und besten Fansongs geben wird bei dieser Weltmeisterschaft. Die Fanfestivals werden sich über 4000 Kilometer durch drei Länder erstrecken. Was auch immer das heißen soll. Einiges davon klingt auch ehrlich gesagt nach KI, aber daran hat man sich ja auch schon gewohnt bei so Presseaussendungen. Ich würde sagen, hier machen wir mal einen ersten Strich, denn es wird ja noch weitere von diesen WM-Panel-Sendungen geben. Ich danke euch dreien sehr, sehr herzlich. Danke an Inga Hofmann vom Tagesspiegel. Schön, dass du mit dabei warst.
Ja, es hat Spaß gemacht. Ich freue mich auf die nächsten Runden.
Ja, ich mich auch schon. Und dann freue ich mich auch, Eva-Lotta Bohle wieder hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Danke dir, liebe Eva. Sensationelles Trikot, das du anhast. Das wissen jetzt nur alle bei YouTube, wovon ich spreche.
Genau, ist Kork City. Falls hinterher Fragen kommen, ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht, irischer Lokalpartey und Tissmus oder so. Aber ich habe schon sehr viel gelernt in dieser Folge. Es hat mir schon sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ich freue mich auf die restlichen Montage mit euch.
Ja, und wir haben ja auch noch einen gemeinsamen Mittwoch. Da wird dann auch Jürgen Kalwa mit dabei sein. Jürgen, vielen lieben Dank, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst hier im Rasenfunk.
Gerne.
Und wenn du mir noch ein Lied schickst, dann werden wir es nach dem Outro holen. Außer ich werde dann geflackt bei YouTube. Das wäre ein Problem, Jürgen. Aber da sprechen wir gleich noch drüber. Ansonsten danke ich natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbungsponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwilligen Zahlungen. Ihr könnt auf rasenfunk.de auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken. Da bekommt ihr alle Informationen, auch was wir mit eurem Geld in der Vergangenheit gemacht haben. Unter anderem zahlen wir natürlich auch Gästehhonorare davon. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Chris V., bei Joris, bei Lukas Herbertson, bei ScrumHalf und bei Flakko-7. Feedback zu dieser Folge sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Die WM, sie wird dann starten mit Mexico gegen Südafrika am Donnerstagabend. Und ihr hört uns am Donnerstag auch in diesem Feed hier wieder. Dann werden wir nochmal etwas größer über die Weltmeisterschaft sprechen und über das erste deutsche Spiel, das ja dann am Sonntag um 19 Uhr deutscher Zeit stattfindet, sprechen wir dann im Nationalteams-Feed. Also solltet ihr den noch nicht abonniert haben, dann unbedingt nachholen. Ansonsten der Hinweis links gibt es in der Podcast- und Videobeschreibung. Und ansonsten werdet oder bleibt gesund und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut. Ciao.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.